what is truth why do we believe the
things we do whom did we believe and why
French philosopher Michel Foucault is
one of the most cited thinkers of the
20th century he died in 1984 but his
work feels particularly timely right now
as it's largely about knowledge truth
and power everything I do I do in order
that it may be a view see once said so
what might Foucault say about the world
today where tones like fate news and
post truth that pandered around and with
the rise of social media and algorithms
focus work is not straightforward or
easy to understand
unlike Marx or Freud Foucault didn't
believe in all-embracing theories to
explain the world life is complicated
and nuanced he argued that language and
the structures that underpin it helps
shape the way we see things words matter
they frame the debate and how we
understand the world
he called this the archaeological method
but he was also interested in
understanding social structures like
capitalism and the complicated pardon
Amex at play in particular the relation
between these past structures and
knowledge he called this the
genealogical method so the
archaeological fukken would be
fascinated by social media and how the
original author of a post can so quickly
disappear from view as the text takes on
a self-replicating life of its own
and more politically engaged
genealogical Foucault would focus on how
it can offer a voice to marginalized
groups immigrants for example and in
some cases even stir up revolution and
the later Foucault profoundly influenced
by ancient Greek and Roman theories
about how we can best care for ourselves
we'll look at how social media can open
up chinks and conventional power
structures gaps where we can transform
ourselves for the better but he would
also say wake up for Kraft both the
careful scholar and the cultural rebel
would sound the alarm about how social
media can trap people and echo chambers
he'd argue that we have imprisoned
ourselves in a system of constant
surveillance giving away so much
personal data about our lives to Google
Facebook YouTube and the rest with
barely a second thought he'd be Colonel
icing how data harvested from our
profiles is being used to control us
without
to infants not just what we see and buy
but also how we vote he will show how
social media can function as yet another
form of micromanagement and be all the
more pervasive and powerful because the
operations underpinning it algorithms
for example a near-invisible
although make us highly visible and
he'll be warning us that as our
awareness grows that we are being
observed and controlled as objects we
will be increasingly likely to monitor
ourselves we will become self
scrutinizing subjects remember the
panopticon he would say this was an
inexpensive way of old-school crowd
control proposed by philosopher Jeremy
Bentham in the late 18th century picture
a central tower and a prison for example
the prisoners can't see in so they never
know whether they're being watched or
not the result they effectively
internalize the surveillance and modify
their own behaviors if they were our
self imprisonment becomes even more
insidious and damaging when the walls
are in fact fake when we are controlled
by fake news replicating a terrifying
speed often unwittingly through our own
actions if we believe the news to be
true than the power to shape our lives
slice not been asked but those who know
it to be false and if in time we come to
think that all news is fake if we become
entirely cynical then we no longer have
the vital tools we need to create
ourselves as individuals or develop our
communities as we'd like but its
Foucault in fact part of the problem
here did he prepare the ground for the
rise of fake news the charge here is
that he denies the possibility of
objective truth and this has opened the
way for claims of competing truths and
alternative facts and Trump's America
and Prix it Britain for example
sometimes he's even accused of helping
to dissolve the boundary between true
and false altogether but this charge is
itself 8 News Foucault had both relish
the irony but also call it out loud and
clear Foucault challenges specific
social sciences about their underlying
assumptions it does not question all
claims to objective truth like those in
maths for example as an activist he
campaigned for accurate factual news
reporting indeed his very notion of the
care of the self is based on ancient
Greek and Roman thinkers who
philosophy is a way of life committed to
truthfulness so Foucault would be
fascinated by the opportunities created
by social media to give a voice to the
voiceless and to fight irony but he
would also be shouting from the
barricades don't become a slave to the
invisible forces
you